Before we say goodbye, let's play a quick round of-
Drewth or Dare.
All right.
All right and here we have Chris Biju.
Hi, Chris.
Hi, how are you.
Thank you for being here.
Of course, of course.
All right, so you have a choice.
You can either have us do Drewth,
or you can dare us to do something.
What's it gonna be?
I'm gonna do a Drewth.
Drewth. Okay, hit it.
So the cooking segments are my favorite
and I love all your recipes,
but I was wondering do you have like a cooking fail?
A cooking fail.
Okay, on the show, my worst, like trigger moment
of I was with Giada de Laurentiis,
and I learned that if you are adding Parmesan
or cheese to your pasta,
making like a Cacio e Pepe for example,
take it off the heat.
Or it will become snotty cob webs, and not this beautiful
like thing that it's supposed to be.
So when you are putting cheese in your pasta,
take it off the heat.
That's something I learned the hard way.
And I really wanted to impress her,
and I just felt like a total toolbar, but I learned.
You learned, but I think you should make mistakes
in the kitchen.
That's why it's there.
There's recipes, but there are no rules
and you will learn from the mistakes.
So get in there, get your hands dirty,
and screw up every once in a while.
All right?
I need you in our dialogue.
Thank you, Chris so very much.
Thank you.
Thank you everyone for spending your time with us.
We make this show for you so please,
take it with you.
Take it with you.
(upbeat bright music)